na also geht doch Berlin hat gewählt und
sogar unfallfrei was eine
Selbstverständlichkeit sein müsste
schafft die deutsche Hauptstadt erst im
Wiederholungsfall immerhin man muss
Berlin alles zutrauen sogar dass es eine
wahlorganisiert bekommt aber die
Berlinerinnen und Berliner sind es leid
Chaos bei Verwaltung und Verkehr zu
wenig Wohnungen silvesterkrawalle all
das hat der CDU die Welle zugetrieben
ihr Spitzenkandidat Kai Wegner schafft
nach mehr als zwei Jahrzehnten einen
historischen Erfolg von der Berliner
Wechselstimmung wurde rot grün rot vor
allem die SPD kalt erwischt eine
persönliche Niederlage auch für die
regierende Franziska Giffey der ist in
anderthalb Jahren nicht gelang genügend
Vertrauen aufzubauen das jetzt getragen
hätte ihr wir haben verstanden kommt
heute zu spät
ja die rot-grün-rote Mehrheit ist da und
darauf hinzuweisen dass auch der
kleinere Partner den Chef stellen kann
ist legitim und nicht unanständig wie es
heute aus der CDU hieß doch richtig ist
dieser Berliner Paukenschlag ist
unüberhörbar und dazu müssen sich jetzt
vor allem die Grünen Verhalten eine
Regierende Bürgermeisterin jarasch mit
einer gedemütigten SPD an der Seite
schwer vorstellbar dafür liegt was
bisher undenkbar erschien jetzt in der
Berliner Luft Schwarz-Grün
Berlin hat gewählt alles andere als nur
eine Wiederholungswahl egal wie es
ausgeht die Aufgabe ist klar es braucht
neue Ideen für eine großartige Stadt in
der zu wenige Menschen an eine gute
Zukunft glauben